your majesty
the king has spoken of heavy
responsibilities
and this is the inescapable reality a
diary of duties meetings with
dignitaries and like any bereaved son
the planning of a funeral
we now know on sunday the queen's coffin
will leave balmoral for the palace of
hollywood house in edinburgh
on monday the king and queen consort
will travel to westminster hall where
both houses of parliament will express
condolences and the king will make his
reply
the queen's coffin will be taken to
saint giles's cathedral in edinburgh the
king and queen consort and other members
of the family will follow the coffin in
a procession
and for 24 hours the coffin will rest in
the cathedral so the public can pay
their respects
that evening the king and other royals
will mount a vigil
on tuesday the king and queen consort
will visit northern ireland
meanwhile that evening the queen's
coffin arrives in london and will rest
at buckingham palace
the following day on wednesday the
coffin will be taken to the palace of
westminster in a silent procession
followed by the king and royal family
the queen's coffin will arrive here at
westminster hall for the lying in state
five days during which members of the
public can pay their respects in person
there will be echoes of the past this is
the lying in state of king george vi in
1952. back then huge queues formed to
file past the coffin
similar scenes are expected now
on friday the king and queen consort
visit wales as their tour of the nations
continues
and on monday the 19th of september the
state funeral a procession will take the
queen's coffin to westminster abbey
the service will start here at 11
o'clock there'll be a bank holiday to
mark the day and afterwards a committal
service at windsor as the late queen is
finally laid to rest
it will be beautifully put together
bringing together all the agencies of
the state and the armed forces with the
finest drill the best pageantry and the
noblest of ceremonial in westminster
abbey it will be
a great salute to a wonderful queen
history tells us there will be huge
crowds last seen at the funeral of the
queen mother
but perhaps none will match the moment
of the final farewell of her daughter
queen elizabeth ii
laura bundock sky news westminster